here we go from The New York Times they
watched Jordan nearly die did they have
a duty to intervene oh interesting are
you supposed to intervene with somebody
crazy when there's a threat are you
supposed to step in and do something
yeah insane and wild I feel like this is
intentionally to make people lose their
minds it's like how is it that they're
gonna go ahead and argue for people to
intervene on Jordan Neely's behalf when
the other guy was intervening on
everyone in the Subway's behalf unreal
it's unbelievable you ready you ready
for this please oh my goodness arrest
everyone that was on that train read one
protester sign love and protect your
fellow man don't move here if you're
scared of your neighbors which it also
added if you watch someone choke and
attack and kill another you are
complicit you are responsible also I
just want to make a point that sign that
says don't move here if you're scared of
your neighbors of course not because if
you're scared of your neighbors you're
already in New York see this is the
thing I wouldn't it doesn't isn't there
a part of all of you that wants everyone
on that train to be arrested no why not
no no because people of New York learn a
lesson about who they voted for and
maybe then no no okay okay you're right
you're right the people of New York will
never learn a lesson forever that's not
true and that's why I say you're right
because the witness the woman who called
Penny Hiro says she wants Giuliani back
yeah like maybe there is a lesson being
learned by people that they might stop
voting for this I can be hopeful I will
I kind of have doubt no one does a
better job creating demand for
Republicans than Democrats yeah I can't
imagine how people are gonna continue to
allow this kind of stuff to happen as
more and more victims are created like
people every day are dealing with this
kind of stuff on on the subway and I
can't imagine again I just can't imagine
the the people of New York actually
supporting it it's got to be activists
that are that are making no noise yeah
well and it's about a you know the
stories the media chooses to focus on so
as we were discussing what an innocent
person is pushed in front of a train by
a complete Maniac that's not a story
that's discussed and then when a citizen
intervenes to prevent somebody who is a
career criminal who's behaving violently
screaming about the fact that they're
not afraid to go back to jail and
they'll kill somebody not only is there
even a question in anyone's mind about
whether this was an appropriate instance
for this person intervening but we're
seeing pictures of the person who died
moonwalking in a subway station is if
that absolves him I just think this this
whole New York Times article is Magic it
is it's hilarious absolute magic it's
like an onion article dude right should
they have a duty to intervene what do
you think Daniel Penny was doing he was
stopping a violent man who was
threatening people he was literally
intervening now in their world you're
like at a bank and some guy breaks in to
rob that bank and the security guard
aims a weapon at the burglar at the bank
robber and the New York Times wants you
to intervene to help the bank robber
that's what they're arguing for and
that's the thing this this isn't just
beyond parody right this isn't just a
joke this is actually a clever joke
right like if the onion or the Babylon
bee published that headline I'd be like
all right that's a good angle because it
shows the hypocrisy and it's also funny
and it's ridiculous this was the New
York Times being completely unironic I'm
I'm I'm often very worried for for Seth
over the Babylon B because yeah I mean
what is he supposed to publish I know
look what about me I make cartoons about
this stuff this is a cartoon this is
actually a cartoon like I do more comedy
than you do at this point by sending
them reading headlines just reading the
news it's true it's really getting to
that point I know but it's terrifying
comedy it's like people are like are you
worried that ai's gonna be able to
generate comedy I'm like the New York
Times already does you can't compete
dude yeah wow when I saw this headline I
was really impressed
because as you pointed out it creates a
paradox of intervention yeah exactly
they're like penny intervenes so then
someone intervenes to stop penny so then
someone intervenes to stop that person
and then everyone in the train is
fighting each other under some legal
requirement exactly and then the next
article is like should the people at the
subway stop have intervened and stopped
everyone on the subway car from stopping
the people in the subway car they were
stopping for about three weeks there
would be no one left in Manhattan
exactly everybody's dead everyone
everyone's just choking each other yeah
they're all it's like a human centipede
of tokens
my gosh
so so where are we on this whole
self-defense thing right
the left doesn't want like we've talked
about you know the left does want to
take away your right to self-defense
because they don't believe that you
should defend yourself against people
that have already been victimized by
Society I've said this before the left
believes that the people that like
Jordan himself was a victim he had been
victimized all his life he was a victim
of circumstance victim of a system etc
etc so when you have someone that's
victimized like that and he's just
acting out in this terrible world that
he's been oppressed in and then the
white man comes and kills him and that's
the way that's the entirety of the left
you know outlook on it and so the the
white guy has come and victimized the
black guy at the end of the day and they
can't abide by the idea that he was
victimized again by historically
powerful people Etc and and it's it's a
simple concept to understand but it
takes all the agency away from every
single person that behaves in a bad way
and it makes excuses for them and you
can't have a society that doesn't have a
standard that is your life is your own
and you can defend it if you have if you
can't defend your own life Society
breaks down exactly so so Jordan Neely
was screaming at innocent people after a
life of crime because of socioeconomic
factors because we didn't fund that
library because his Public School wasn't
good enough for on par with European
standards or standards and more wealthy
neighborhoods it's an imaginary standard
but Daniel Penny he just woke up and
wanted to kill a black person right
that's the only analysis we do on the
fact that somebody is dead on this train
right he just woke up one morning and
said I just I guess I just want to go
out and kill a black person that is
literally how the left sees the story
every single level of socioeconomic
analysis is done to exonerate Jordan
Neely but they're lying like they don't
literally believe that I just lie I
think so I think you're right that they
lie but there are True Believers on the
left who if you really press them or you
just try to infer from their conclusions
they really seem to believe that white
people are just searching for excuses to
kill black people all the time there are
people because every time there's an
instance where a white person defends
themselves against a black person it's
well oh look at that white guy killed a
black guy because he's racist really
that's the first that's the first
assumption weren't you saying something
earlier about your hands being deadly
weapons like is that like a law or
something yeah so that's a law when you
become a pro professional fighter you
have to register your hands with the
police no yes you had to go to the
police and tell them I mean you're
supposed to I never ended up doing it
because I knew I was never gonna break a
law like I handle my business in the
cage where we get paid a lot of money to
to fight people I would never assault
someone outside the cage so you know I I
I would never have to deal with that so
I heard that I heard that when I was
little they said that if you're if you
get like a black belt then it like as a
kid they say it makes your hands deadly
weapons as an adult I was told it makes
uh assault aggravated like if you're a
trained fighter and you commit a crime
it's an aggravated crime as if a regular
person had a weapon and you being
trained aggravates it or something yeah
well I remember before the show you were
telling a story about somebody who was a
wrestler and got in some trouble yeah so
there was this wrestler in my in my
college of Oregon State and uh he uh got
in a fight at a party because the guy
was like cussing at his girlfriend so
he's like dude I'm not you're not gonna
cuss at my girlfriend then the guy like
pushed him and like threw a punch in my
Sucker Punch so he's like let's go
outside so he took it outside double
legs the guy on the ground the guy hits
his head off the concrete and had to get
stitches and then goes to the police and
ends up my friend ended up getting
assault with a deadly weapon because he
was a wrestler that's insane crazy ended
up having to do three and a half years
in prison no oh my gosh that's why I
always tell people like the fight's not
worth it yeah I mean like you're saying
fight in the fight in the cage make it
professional but I've heard too many
stories about people who they get
emotional yeah
and you know nine times out of out of 10
99 times out of 100 fights usually break
up someone gets a bruise nobody is kind
of the end of it
you get that one moment where someone
falls back and hits their head and you
and you go to prison yeah it's not worth
it man
it's tough though when the adrenaline
gets going like people don't know how to
control their adrenaline rushes like
it's a real thing like when you're in
that type of moment where it's like high
intensity and you feel like you know
you're about to get in a fight like the
adrenaline the nerves start getting to
you and you know you can't handle your
emotions you don't think clearly anymore
so you know I I kind of I feel for those
people I think I think more people
should probably do some kind of fight
training because even thinking about
situations like this with uh with Penny
he's a Marine he was probably cool as a
cucumber like everyone else is freaking
out he's probably thinking like all
right I got I got to stop this guy
before it gets out of hand and that's
why he was able to do it and then those
other guys help him do it but you get
someone who's terrified and shaking and
things can get a lot worse than than
they did here like
in New York when you get cops who are
poorly trained and they start unloading
their their guns and then this actually
happened they ended up shooting seven
random people because they were
panicking and just like people need to
be able to be be in control that was at
the Empire State Building right yeah
yeah yeah did you guys hear that story
yeah no a guy came out of the building I
guess he had it was like a disgruntled
shooting or something yeah I'm not sure
what it was but the police unloaded and
they shot him but I think they missed
him well I mean the thing is they were
using nine millimeters so they may have
missed him but they also may have hit
him and they just go pass through
because they're fast they hit like seven
random people just like because they
were just like ah we're just shooting
like terrified of this guy and I mean it
could have been you know ricochets or
whatever but still you know yeah you're
shooting guns in New York City like just
because you're cops doesn't mean the
bullets stopping the bad guy or you know
they don't bounce or whatever so
um gotta be careful man yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there